ドンドンドンドンキ
ドンキホーデー
夜中に行ったら dqn に絡まれる
あー肇社長だ写真とって優しいねいいだろうねぇ
[音楽]
怖いよーっこいつはずの社長ですよなに後輩とドンキに行ったときに衝撃っていいな超
衝撃的なセールを見つけてしまいました
あの大抵過去に入ってるこんな a セールみたいねズってまあある程度でなんだ
わかると思うよ橙とか買わなきゃ損即尺遠征
今と海賊今かを書いて1000円セールワンコイン版声500円っていろんな性がある
んでしょ俺が方
が見つけたセルは世の中の上リアタゲ前を覆している
こちらなんとこのな web 10円
すごいやビビットビットマジフルートフルートよく考えてみてくださいよドンキホーテ
といえどもさすがに10円でモードが売ってることなんてそうそうないんですよものっ
て案外高く売るから初めてでーきーがでってくだその10年のカートの中に入ってた
ものはつチェーン以下の存在なんですよ
でもそんな順位かでものが作れることなんてそうそうないからもう買うだけと無難です
よやばいやばい俺を
どうすよと思った僕はもう気づいたら一緒に広範囲なんですけどもう見ないようにした
まま後輩にそのカートの中の10円整備されていたものをすべて川瀬ました
持ってこさせましょう
これに入れてもらったねそんな
彼らはもう10円って聞いた瞬間買った瞬間後になると思ったらもう全部買いました
単価10円以下んのその後なんて方ないから基本的に何が出てきても僕は嬉しいはず
です確実に暮らせて利益になってるとこっちがのちなみに領収書はありますか
多いなあ60国台はあったと思うんだよね6しっ
ブーバー ean 4大都市間あっ
ブリッジ部犯すテニス50円郡まあ多分全駅参加です800ほど買ったとしても発生
もう俺は全部買うしかないと思って俺はもう全部1ビジネス靴冷たかったので適当に見
ていこうと思いますで猫
結構そもそもの話ですよ8件これから海軍というか見てるわけでしょつを流れ作業で
いいんですか
それで皆さん僕がこれを10円で手に入る
たという認識で見てもらえると良いですそれにそれでもサワーすげー入って涙瞬間決め
ますそれが10円で買ったことによってプラスなのか by やつなのか
月一発目
はい
何
クソチュッパチャップスのシールですね-ねこれから出来るのか
こわいなちょっとこうやってきたはいでかいをえっ
右スピーカー大菅 usb で聴けるスピーカー中で手に入ったと+なんかこういう
感じでどんどん良い奴が来るよねああ
べキュレーションシールが-800全部見るの面倒くせえなあとバット言っちゃカード
ワットいざ
ちょっとこれきりがないぞ1個ずつ見てたら日が暮れ一番こんなだから僕が選りすぐっ
てちょっとイエスを探していきましょう
こちらの商品全部中になっておりますやー
はぁ
[音楽]
を覚え異質な待ってこれも曹丕にボロボロだろうなあとは一家にプラスのものがここに
あるかどうかって言うんですね
パッと見ていきましょうかパッと見に何かやったね分かんね月末技とかもあるからな
がすぐアイロンシールとかないくるして d 変換アダプター例えばシール系が多い
ですねポジでシール鍵またラインサーブ買うからな
タトゥーシール活動
z テーマバトルこういうことで右手ミスあるんですけどもうこれ使わねーなー保た
せるコツぽいするってどんの選抜していきましょう僕が勝ってよかったと思うような
ものがではお店も僕も
幸せなら ok です梅塚しなんか匂いな芳香剤みたいなのがあるけど古い綱田悠久の
時を感じる
[音楽]
狂いなぁなる大問題だ系の時の充電器とかあるけど今使えないからな
i love voxy って書いてるバーンやーまてぃおいおいおいおいおいおい
おい気に入ってないっていうねちょっと時本当原点復帰版がも中身入ってないんです
けど
うわーこ
絶対誰かとっっ
[音楽]
でゴキブリだ
new ついわー
dee
大トリ825点全部見て官兵衛した結果僕の賊団で偏見だと大体これぐらいあります
ってまず女性だったらこれ12だったらお得なんじゃねーかんっていうのはこれです胸
がキレイになるなんか
胸行タッグみたいなやつです願って角質が落ちるみたいでこれを使うとねなんか胸が
クビになる的なずらしいですね
これがロックパックありました水でこっち
ラプンツェルの鏡ですまあこれが100円なら普通の得じゃねぇかな来られた南くん
です
商品が汚れると売れなくなるんでそれで登っちゃったんじゃないかな洗えば多分使える
と思うんで僕は価値があると思ったよ
こちらハンドパンツこれを2にすってねこれ締めてやばいでしょ高精度な紙に穴を
開ける的な奴なんですこれ10円はかなり暑いと思いました合格アタック
小澤ですながら横浜の柔軟剤ねこれを10円はもうやばいをもうお母さんが泣いて喜ぶ
順でスピーカーなんですけど使い方がよくわからないので学んでも10円で回だと思っ
たらまあエンチャって感じです次半ばキャディっぽい[ __ ]の使うカバーみたいな多分
スマホ入れるのかのわかんないですけどこれも中高いだというからまあまあお得なん
じゃないんでしょうかぼがよくわかっ
ないですけどねつぎこれはもう優勝でしょこちらなんかトイレする時に夫がなって
くれるからブリブリブリッだったらやっぱり痩せないですかそういうときにこれをこの
も単発って押すとその音がかき消される的なやつこれが10円でや本当にだけなのかな
こうしてみます
マイナスイオンブレスレット普通にチェーン鳥にこれで10円は安いと思いました
ところですね芳香剤車に付ける芳香剤みたいなやつ非常に汚い
ああこれだご飯ならパッカーと思ったらてのてのパックと
ず優先にこれでヘアピン金全部17すごいお得だと思いました畑なく網タイツと
ストッキングがありましたまた個人的にかわいい固いは本弱とか普通にベター
ハンドクリームとかまず中妻後周りのでケーブルとかなんですけどもタブーがら計8日
がプレーから使えないんだよ
また雇用花パックとか劇団でパスキーですとかたい方用のクリーナーとか日はいい歯
医者どうか
あとアイシャドウオフィスビルで包め熱爪ネクタイパリ病対策サングラスコッシーの
彼女フック
こういう防犯ステッカーが10円とかはすごいな感じ
よかったなと思いましたあとメリットはコンディショナーガツンと言ってた後は謎に8
って書いてあるキーホルダーですねピンポイントすぎるんだよな
罰ゲームで書いてあるやつが出来るみたいなやつっぽいですはいだけで埋めていった
わけなんですけどもう良いか悪いかは置いて僕自身がンってよかったって思うわー
てる25品中良いもう買わねー
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ